when I was a kid I watched old movies
almost exclusively and I'm bringing this
up because I want to bring it around to
Barry that's I have to say this is and
not just because we're friends or
anything it is I think the best show on
TV I absolutely love it thank you man
thank you um now keep in mind I don't
see a lot of stuff yeah and he's never
seen this I've never I've never seen
this yeah I don't watch Barry I've never
seen succession yeah exactly no it is uh
I just love what you're doing with this
show and I know that that this season
you uh directed and I every episode yeah
every episode and so I I kind of just
wanted to go back for a second and think
explore there's you you clearly are such
a classic film buff and it comes through
in your choices as a director and you
take that really seriously and I know
that I think you were telling me once
when you were a kid you'd go over to
sleepovers and people thought oh these
kids are probably watching you know
porno yeah right it's like no you were
watching A Clockwork Orange yeah right
Taxi Driver yeah I was watching Taxi
Driver yeah studying like and studying
the shots yeah yeah exactly yeah no one
was interested in that or it was like
see how the camera it's like a
subjective camera move
why the hell you in my house
the father comes in and tidy whities not
just here subjective camera moves
where the hell you come from
I want you to get out of my house
looks like we gotta say there was a film
buff
it was more nerve-wracking for that no
but it was yeah you would watch that or
watch old movies and it's just what you
were kind of interested in it was you
know what the thing that you can't
describe the thing that you're attracted
to that is what happens and when I would
watch movies I remember you know my mom
liked actors and things like that and
what always captured me was kind of the
the story or the the way it was shot or
the design of it and uh just recently
you know I I have three daughters and
and uh I showed them a rear window and
it was fascinating because it started
they went yeah this is like old you know
13 10 and eight they're eight and
they're just this is boring why are we
watching this please no and then
as it went on they were getting more and
more into it and well and then it gets
to this point which is one of my
favorite Parts in any Hitchcock movie if
you can remember the movie where uh
Grace Kelly goes and gets she goes and
gets in the Raymond Burr's apartment
yeah the Killer's apartment and he comes
home and then there's that great moment
where she finds the wife's ring and she
has the ring and she's she's trying to
show Jimmy Stewart across the street
like I found the ring and then the
camera pans up and Raymond Burr is seen
that she's doing that and he looks right
in the camera he sees he sees Jimmy
Stewart Jimmy Stewart so he now knows
I'm being watched and I now know what's
happening and when he did that all three
of my daughters just went
and I thought okay this guy made this in
the 50s early 50s and there's just
nothing that you can do whatever you
want in movies whatever but if you have
good storytelling and craftsmanship this
is what you get it's Timeless you know
and it really made me
that's why I keep going back to those
because it's just like it's just the
bare bones craft of it hey whether
you're stuck in traffic or streaming
your favorite podcasts that's where I
come in it's important to have a network
you can trust wherever you are say it
with me T-Mobile mobile yeah you didn't
really have to say it with me but it is
your network you know I'm excited about
T-Mobile yeah you're killing it and uh
you know I was really excited is our
good friend blay who's been using this
service blade tell us about it yeah I
have been a T-Mobile a subscriber for a
really long time it they're awesome I
download videos all the time yeah you do
you like you download a lot of videos
yeah now you've never read a book no no
books are overrated but uh and I listen
to this podcast on a hike fantastic up
in the mountains you listen to our
podcast I will contract you work here
yeah I have to I have to I have to
listen to it but it's great and and
honestly like the coverage is is insane
uh and yeah I love the service I love
the phone it's fantastic experience for
yourself how T-Mobile is America's
largest and fastest 5G Network you can't
top them I like all the G's you bet you
do find out more at t-mobile.com Cy
that's
s-e-e-w-h-y fastest based on median
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data 4.
Q4 2022 good wow that's incredible yeah
I said exactly what they wanted me
5G details at t-mobile.com I love that
you bring up
um showing these to your kids because
it's I always have feel like I have so
much on the line when I show these
movies that I love to my kids especially
when they were younger because if they
weren't having it I felt destroyed
but I showed them not too long ago uh I
showed them
um
uh uh a deep throat no no yeah
deep throat yeah and you know what it's
it's got a lot of subjective camera
moves
[Music]
I don't remember this kids I don't
remember this part I'm sorry I saw this
in the theater I was wearing an Overcoat
in the 70s you couldn't you couldn't get
this stuff online back no no she but the
Times Square doesn't look like Times
Square looks like back then it had a
real life you know subjective camera
move look at all these subjective Dolly
shots don't you think there are all
those people like that purists that are
still wearing a raincoat while they are
on their computer watching porn like
artisanal vintage jokes yeah they're
just like you know this is how you do it
yeah and they're making their friends
dress up like an usher like in 15
minutes come in and kick me out of my
room
this guy's spending thousands of dollars
to hire people hipster masturbaters yeah
yeah Hipster masturbaters right yeah
what was the film you were gonna uh just
fixed so I can say it uh where he's you
know why am I blanking on he gets dizzy
when he oh Vertigo Vertigo Vertigo I
don't know why old age the one where he
gets dizzy
vertigo like just a movie where you got
dizzy
it's the one the shower movie
[Laughter]
I showed my kids
vertigo with some friends of mine and
they're watching it and at least they
were old enough to appreciate because I
went on a riff at one point about you
know because it's kind of crazy Jimmy
Stewart takes uh takes this kind of
Dana's bit beautiful blonde woman up and
yeah up in this Tower uh and then you
know she
goes flying out of the Tower and so then
he comes back later on to the same
Mission with uh uh you know Kim Novak
with Kim Novak and I just do him running
into a nun and saying I'm just we're
gonna get one more try here you see
we're sure
you were here once we're the blonde who
looks exactly she died she died
I think I'm some sort of a creep
and then I do him going after the second
the second one like ah kind of land in
the same spot
I uh the wind must catch oh I got the
Winchester a bit and that's she's
yelling right where the tiles meet the
eaves yeah and my kids were like
laughing at that and I thought okay at
least we have all right yeah it's a it's
okay it's funny that yeah you try to
watch those old movies and sometimes
they work but then man it sometimes when
they when the my daughter had a big
sleepover with a bunch of friends and
I'm usually downstairs watching an old
movie they're upstairs like you know
whatever singing karaoke and you know
singing carry a pair you know Katy Perry
songs or whatever and then they came
down I was watching this movie called
Jeopardy
um
with Barbara stanwig
and it's basically a story about these
this this couple and their child go to
Mexico and the the father played with
Barry Sullivan somehow gets stuck under
like a a there's a dilapidated boardwalk
and he gets stuck under like a like a
piece of it like a log and the Tide's
Rising so he's like you need to go get
me help and so she leaves her son there
she goes out to get help and she finds
Ralph Meeker and she goes and you do and
he is an escape convict right so you're
cutting back to Barry Sullivan the
waters up to his neck yep and he's
talking to his son going like don't know
what he said it's gonna be all right
uh can you just set your pants on fire
son Let's make a beacon and all this and
then she's with this killer and my my
kids uh and then I turn around and like
more of these kids are coming in behind
me and they're watching it okay and
they're just totally they go how's she
gonna get back to the you know what I
mean and I'm like it's that simple you
know and I came into the edit Bay the
next day of Barry and I was like it's
that it really isn't that hard if you
just can you know tell a good story
right that's what it's gonna be and so I
get that's why I get very inspired by
that stuff